these days the idea of erasing something
like a film from existence is kind of
ridiculous nothing disappears completely
still that doesn't mean the studio's
haven't occasionally done their best to
bury a particularly embarrassing film
here are some movies that Studios tried
and mostly failed to erase from
existence Fantastic Four famously filmed
on a budget of around 1 million dollars
the 1994 Fantastic Four film was never
officially released being unexpectedly
canceled just a few weeks before its
official premiere since then however
low-quality bootleg copies of the film
have found their way onto both the
internet and DVD according to legend the
film was so bad that the then executive
at Marvel Entertainment avi arad bought
the rights to the film moments after
seeing an advanced copy and ordered that
it be canceled to protect the Marvel
brand
Arad would later claim that he
additionally ordered every remaining
copy of the film be destroyed
well the joke's on Marvel the film Arad
thought was so bad that it had to be
buried has a higher rotten tomato score
than two of the three Fantastic Four
films that have been released since
[Music]
the big boss Mandarin cut regarded as
the film that made Bruce Lee famous at
least in Asia the big boss is your
standard 1970s Hong Kong action movie
and features all of the Bruce Lee
staples fans would eventually come to
expect in his movies the only problem is
a big chunk of the movie is missing
before it was released the original cut
of the big boss was effectively
destroyed by Hong Kong censors known as
the Mandarin cut this more complete
version of Bruce Lee's first major film
was more violent and countless scenes
were altered or completely cut from the
movie it's highly unlikely the Bruce Lee
fans will ever see a complete version of
the film but all of its cut content but
back in largely because nobody knows if
it still exists Citizen Kane colorized
version there's little that can be said
about Citizen Kane that hasn't already
been said so let's just talk about that
time in the late 1980s when media mogul
Ted Turner decided it would be a good
idea to try and fix Citizen Kane by
colorizing it according to an interview
with colorist William Shafer at least 10
minutes of Citizen Kane was colorized
before the project was put to a stop a
friend of orson welles later claimed
that one of the last things the director
said was don't let Ted Turner to face my
movie with his crayons depending on who
you ask
the colorized footage was either shelved
or erased today only around a minute of
the footages emerged most recently in an
obscure 90s BBC documentary about the
film the Star Wars Holiday Special
until the prequels came along the Star
Wars Holiday Special was long considered
the single worst piece of Star Wars
content ever made it aired only once and
the special was quickly swept under the
rug by Lucasfilm George Lucas was
reportedly very disappointed in the
special and he saw to it that it was
effectively buried by having it left out
of complete edition box sets and
forbidding TV stations from arrogant
according to legend only one person had
an official copy of the special Carrie
Fisher who claims she received one in
trade for recording the commentary of
one of the Star Wars DVD boxsets why did
she want a copy she said that she wanted
something she could play at parties when
she wanted people to leave
superstar the Karen Carpenter story
released in 1987 superstar the Karen
Carpenter story is a short film that
chronicles the final years of singer
Karen Carpenter's life only instead of
using archived footage or actors the
film was made almost entirely with
Barbie dolls just a couple of kids next
door although the film was intended to
provide a sympathetic overview of
carpenter's life and the struggle she
faced it was decidedly less kind to her
family her brother Richard suit director
Todd Haynes for unlicensed use of the
carpenters music and virtually all
copies of the film were quietly
destroyed Haynes himself was banned from
ever airing the personal copy he had
tucked away this didn't stop resourceful
fans today several low-quality versions
have surfaced on YouTube Nosferatu
considered by film buffs to be one of
the most influential horror movies ever
made
Nosferatu was among the first films to
adapt Brahm Stoker's Dracula to the big
screen
the problem was Stoker's widowed never
gave anyone permission to make the movie
the first thing she did after the film
came out was super on a film the studio
that released it when the courts ruled
that the film was a blatant ripoff of
Stoker's novel they ordered that every
copy be destroyed in order that was
carried out so thoroughly it's believed
only a single copy of the film survived
the purge this copy then circulated over
the coming decades until the copyright
on the Dracula novel expired and the
film could come back to life thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]
you